it's et's social study what the stars
are posting online Nicky Hilton looks
better than ever flashing her flat
post-baby tummy after a workout we're
glad to bring Luna here for the first
time moving on chrissy teigen and john
legend take daughter Luna to meet the
Easter Bunny and it's too cute to handle
little luna looks pretty in pink while
smiling for her close-up another
adorable kid posing with the Easter
Bunny Jamie Lynn Spears daughter Maddie
from an Easter egg hunt to holding an
alligator during a swamp tour field trip
Jamie appeared to have a fun filled day
with her eight-year-old look-alike who's
doing much better after an ATV accident
earlier this year meanwhile Kevin Hart
has an adorable dance-off with his
daughter
christina aguilera celebrates her fiance
matt rutler birthday with their daughter
summer who is growing up fast mika wish
about the candid addy tell me nah then
there's hilary duff showing off the
first present her five-year-old son luca
picked out for her by himself a Wonder
Woman watch I absolutely loved it
castano it just slid boonton and Beyonce
continues to celebrate her 9 year
wedding anniversary with jay-z with
never-before-seen photos queen bee
shared a series of cute flashback pics
from the couple's anniversary trip to
the Grand Canyon with daughter Blue Ivy
last year
[Music]